what i want to talk about is as you may
have noticed we live in a culture that
seems to have
completely lost its mind
we are
living through a period of mass
psychosis that is very truly
unprecedented in the history of human
civilization it seems as though all at
once millions of our countrymen
sort of woke up one day having forgot
some of the most basic facts about
reality like a giant epidemic of just
the weirdest sort of amnesia
and lying at the heart of this
intellectual chaos is the confusion or
apparent confusion anyway
over human biology
a a mental disease called gender
ideology has gripped hold of a large
swath of the american public
and totally taken over almost all of our
or in fact all of our most powerful
institutions
the disciples of this cult have been
convinced or pretend to be convinced
anyway that men are women women are men
that you know men can have babies women
can have penises that a woman can
impregnate a man who can then give birth
to and breastfeed a child
that's somehow the most basic facts
about reality and about biology facts
which all people everywhere across the
entire world for thousands and thousands
of years all recognized intuitively
are no longer valid
it's total madness and it's a madness
which has infected our society and now
is threatening i think to tear it apart
at the seams already is in fact doing
that
it was for this reason that i along with
my uh extraordinary team at the daily
wire decided that we had to make a film
which just premiered on the daily wire
and has angered the left so much that
there was even
and still is a sustained cyber attack on
the site to shut us down and prevent
people from seeing it
along with all the other tricks they're
they're pulling around this thing
the film is called what is a woman and
it documents
my year-long journey to confront and
expose gender ideology
uh it was a journey that took us all
over the the country from san francisco
to seattle to new york
many places in between
it took us even across the world deep
into the bush in kenya
took us to other third world countries
too like los angeles for example
now
our goal broadly was to
explore gender ideology to kind of show
it for what it is
and as the title suggests this larger
goal centers around one seemingly quite
simple and specific question
what is a woman